Hi good morning good morning Professor Cristina
thank you for accepting to answer the 21
questions of Google Global teacher
prize today is my house ok what did you eat
for breakfast today
and always counts with all
our backyard a little powder with
fruit jam  everything I make from the fruit I
have my Orchard Ed the milk and coffee here
is my place of inspiration it is my
office it is a place where I work
when I get home how do you
go to school every day
and how long  takes the trip to the
school but today is the 27th by face
we don't have students at school those
our students will return i hope that in
person with all their strength in all
their energy and joy no one could 1417
september however i would love to
show you  where is the school where
I work since the 14th of
February this year but it is said that not
only to pick up my little girl my son is
on summer vacation he is not at home and
in the Joaquim which is the most important moment  s new to the
family we can go to school Yes we can
good and even thanks what you think When
I entered school every day every
day I think about giving the best that this
was planted difference and I was that
transformative of going to school but
not today  namely students with
special educational needs, the
school makes a difference in this regard for
these students and I think that it is important and
decisive and that the school should
promote quality of life,
namely it should have a move
two more areas that are still little
being worked on in the  portuguese schools
so that the domain of rights and the
domain and self-determination
I prefer one thing that now in your
school teamwork The team
completed the work currently loves the
team I respect a lot a sharing of
knowledge and he told Dr Rosa
Carvalho the  support that you have given me in these
last months of profession I don't know
who your favorite movie star is, he
put on the music What is the  me
favorite singer or band singer George
Michael and Microscope band but
also Pink Floyd who is your hero my
husband and my parents my husband is
always present in good times and
bad times MA
with whom
to live life ok likes  travel I
like to travel don't have much
possibility to do Which place
would I love to visit Maldives I
really like the beach before I became a teacher
naturally and secondly because the following
natural path was a student what was the
subject that I most liked to learn in
school history  and sticking to eat them
I liked them I didn't like the multiplication table at all
because I remember attracts me in the second year
at school of not knowing a multiplication table and
vase regulated herbs and to this day I have
unfortunately this brand and this experience
and by the negative so multiplication tables are
not  forget that everything is numbers
what kind of student was it at school
me and the hand in calm interested
Responsible to do we have jobs no
and how do you  in problems
and what is the food they prefer o What is the
favorite food that in the
school canteen and formed them at lunch at
school thank God comes home for lunch at
my parents' house but I love having a
coffee in the middle of the morning it's a  delight
I know what time I'm going to leave school
because of six in the afternoon I usually
continue to work as soon as I get
home every day I have an iPod extension it
's a lot of work normally the holidays
I say the most and the
related information I tell you the  more
research in the field of quality of
life and saturdays
teacher training at a national level that a
life is not just work you usually do it
to relax relax I like listening to
music I like swimming, walking and I also really
enjoy being on the beach and swimming
appointments What are your passions o
eggs outside of school mom I have very
little free time however when I have
some time I really like to read a good
book a creative book I like to paint
and mine  Jardim da jardinar don't get dirty
coping I love flowers and and I
really like tips in your career What is the
proudest achievement as a
teacher I would say that the relationship you
establish with my students and
parents with the paths these my students
are proud of is  a great pride for me to be
able at this moment to walk through her gate and
see my former students when the most
trash tests but who are married have a
job recently I met
Luna's middle daughter of mine and it was an
aurio moment because effectively we looked  and
we thought well our role was well
run so much my greatest pride is to have
invested and believed in the concept of
quality of life and apply it in
Special Education to have created the
personal scale I have results for both
adults and children 1
the power to apply  in order to
effectively change the lives of each of these
students and each of these products exist
that scale and concept the quality of
life has made a difference in the life of the
test individuals what is the most
important advice you would give your students
me my students would say that you believe to
always believe above all despite
the obstacles we have but also
fight for your dreams and
if you can write a quote a
motivational situation which one would you choose none  that
being different is not a crime 1
G1
and it is not a crime for something different it is not a
crime to have a different teacher it
is because the difference is an added value
for everyone is
accepting and finally because you chose to be a
teacher this is not the time for
me  I can say that meeting a teacher is
always wanted to be a teacher whenever I
remember as a person I wanted to be a
teacher Good afternoon or to Júlia that the
director of the school where I
currently work for another Júlia all
right thank you And so
we always have to take care of  children mine
have two younger brothers and there is an
account that the others but of my cousins
e colleagues who have been to ca
sa and so we arrived at our accounts
we have already seen the director of the school
why because we actually cross paths
with mine is i think that was it
and
within teaching because
special education special education because
probably from a colleague who
had an intellectual difficulty
during the first cycle and this colleague
a taste of this hole in the other India the
subjects that marked a lot by the negative
that's why today I believe here  it is
possible to help some of these individuals to
have exactly the same rights that
any citizen has and therefore this is
my motto this is my battle this is
my mission and this is the main objective
of the quality of life work And
we arrived at school we know  the
director I thank the Global teacher prize
and I appreciate the interview with my brother-
in-law of clay and I thank you and it's always
good to see a professional  nal to speak with
such brilliance and with such pride of
what he does thank you